herkese
Merhabalar hoşgeldiniz Ben Zeynep
özdeyiş Çetin sizde bu akşam öğrenmekle
bilmek ile ilgili bir hikaye anlatmak
istiyorum öğrenmekle Bilmek acaba aynı
mıdır diye böyle bir Sizi düşünmeye
yönlendirmek istiyorum Bence farklı
Bu nedenle ben size bunu nasıl
keşfettiğini öyküsünü de aktarmak
istiyorum az önce de söylendiği gibi
Çanakkale Belediyesi'nde 15 yıl İmar ve
şehircilik müdürü olarak görev yaptım Bu
on beş yılın sonunda Belediye Başkan
Yardımcısı görevliye görevli başladım ve
yedi senedir de belediye başkan
yardımcısı olarak Çanakkale
Belediyesi'nde çalışıyorum ve tabi
belediye başkanı ne iş yapar aşağı
yukarı herkes biliyor Çünkü onu Sizler
seçiyorsunuz ama belediye başkan
yardımcılarının Ne iş yaptığı konusunda
belki herkesin hakkında hemen bir şey
gelmeyebilir Biz belediye başkan ve
doğru olarak ki çok sevdiğim arkadaşım
mesai arkadaşım raviye Ünüvar da sayılır
Eminönü vardı burada belediye başkan
vekili olarak bulunuyor birlikte
belediyenin yaptığı tüm hizmetlerin
yürütümü yapıyoruz bu hizmetler ne
aklınıza gelebilecek Neredeyse her şey
temizlikten ulaşıma ulaşımdan imara
imardan yeşil alanlara yeşil alanlardan
projelere su theremine Sosyal hizmetlere
kadar çok geniş bir yelpazede hizmet
sunmaya çalışıyoruz tabi bunları ben ve
diğer üç arkadaşım toplam dört kişiyiz
ve bu dört kişinin üç tanesi kadın büyük
bir özveri ve zevkle yapıyoruz Tabi bu
aşamaya gelebilmek için ben neler
katettim neler yaşadım sizinle bunları
paylaşmak istiyorum Öncelikle ilk orta
ve lise yıllarımda her zaman çok
sevdiğim bir mesleğin olsun istemiştim
bir meslek adı koyma Mıştım Aslında
Bazen ufak tefek sapmalar yaşamıştım bu
bu mantar Doktor olmak istemiştim bir
arada kaptan kusto ama onun dışında Hep
sevdiğim işi yapmak istemiştim özellikle
lise yılları benim için çok zorlu geçti
ilkokul sırasında ilk Okul Yıllarım
sırasında hocam da burada zaten çok iyi
bilir aynı zamanda basketbol oynamaya
başladım bu basketbol aşkı ilkokulda çok
daha kolaydı fakat sonraki yıllarda
Ortaokulda sonrasında lisede bayağı
zorlayıcı bir hal almaya başladı çünkü
spor yapanların derslerini aksattığı
gibi bir maalesef kanı vardı Ve ben bunu
ortadan kaldırabilmek için ekstradan
daha çok çalışmaya yaptığım her işte
daha çok başarılı olmaya odaklandım Tabi
o dönemki bu yoğun çalışmalar birden
fazla işi aynı anda yapabilmenin mümkün
olabildiğini ve bu işleri birlikte
yürütmenin Aslında çok da zevkli
olduğunu bana gösterdi bu dönemde
stresli ve yorucu bir ortamda de bu
çalışabilmek için geceleri tercih
ediyorum çünkü gündüzleri spor ve okulda
doluydu geceleri de lise döneminde
üniversiteye Ayrıca hazırlanmam
gerekiyordu
erbuyurucu başarılı bir yolculuğu yorucu
süreç başarılı bir sonuca ulaştı bu
süreçte de üniversitede özellikle
istediğim ve ilk tercihim olan bölümü
kazandım şu sayenizde
de gerçekten burada şunu öğrendim gel
konsantre olup bir şey gerçekten
odaklanırsanız ve bunu isteyerek
yaparsanız Biz her şey daha kolay
olabiliyor Bu yüzden odaklanmak
konsantre olmak ve hırslanmak bir şeye
ulaşmak için önemliymiş onu fark ettim
şimdi mocool yaşantımda bu anlayışlı hiç
sıkıntı yaşamadım İstanbul Teknik
Üniversitesi Mimarlık Fakültesi Şehir ve
Bölge Planlama Bölümü ne girdim ve
bitirdi Ben o zamanlar Bu bölüm çok
fazla bilinmiyordu ve çok az sayıda
mezun veriyordu ama ben şanslıydım
matematik hocamız yönlendirmesiyle böyle
bir bölüme yöneldim mesleği biliyordum
Ne iş yapacağını biliyordum ve hedefime
uygundu
sor hayatım
üniversiteye hayatım kadar başarılı
geçmedi sıkıntılar yaşadım sakatlıklar
Yaşadım ve üniversite döneminden sonra
Basketbol oynamayı bırakmak zorunda
kaldım ama hala aktif olarak spor
yapıyorum yüzüyorum koşuyorum ama basket
topu gördüğüm zaman pota gördüm zamanda
kendimi tutamıyorum mutlaka basketbol
oynuyorum e 1995 yılında mezun oldum ve
beklenmedik bir şekilde benim yerel
yönetim maceram başladı Aslında bunu hiç
düşünmemiştim o zamana kadar daha bir
kere oy kullanmıştım ve belediyelerin ne
iş yaptığını bilmiyordum belediyede
çalışmak gibi bir düşün bu yoktu ve
belediye benim için fiziki binadan
ibarettim o zaman her zaman birçok
öğrencinin düşündüğü gibi bir açarım
İşte yurt dışına Çıkarım ya da okulda
kalırım gibi böyle çok da muallak bazı
fikirlerim vardı hatta İstanbul'da
okuduğum için Oradan daha dönmemişti bir
karar vereyim diye kendi kendime oy
alıyordum bir yılbaşı tatili için
Çanakkale'ye gelmiştim Çanakkale'de
yılbaşı tatiline geçirdikten Sonra
tatil henüz bitmiştik Çanakkale
Belediyesi'nden bir telefon geldi
bilgisayar ve planlama konuları ile
ilgili ikisinin birleştiği bir çalışma
yapılacağı yönünde bir çağrı aldım
şu m o zamanlar bilgisayar Bu kadar
yaygın olmadığı için bilgisayarda
planlamada ancak okullarda okutulan bir
ders olduğu için çok fazla da
bilinmiyordu herhalde beni dedim
planlama yapmayı bilgisayarda Çizim
yapmayı biliyor yardımcı olsun diye
çağırdılar
var ama sonradan öğrendim ki aslında
Bunun nedeni çok başkaymış o dönemki
belediye başkanımız da babam bir yerde
sohbet ediyorlar işte Belediye Başkanı
babama soruyor Senin kız nerede okuyor
ne olacak falan diye Babam da diyor ki
benim kız diyor şey yok yok bu şehir
plancısı olacak bilgisayarda planlama
yapıyor falan diyor o zaman ki belediye
başkanı hakkında bu kalıyor ve çizimle
planlamayla ve bilgisayarla ilgili bir
iş olunca a Bunu bilen birini tanıyorum
diye beni hatırlıyor bu sohbet hayatım
için belirleyici bir sohbet oldu
sabah Telefon geldi Ben de yani ev
kıyafeti öğrenci kıyafeti ile Hadi ayıp
olmasın diye Belediyeye gittim ve bir
odaya girdik odada bir Eğitmen var üç
kişi var bir tanesi burada Ayşe Hanım
üçümüz bir de
bilgisayar var herhalde dedim bu böyle
bir eğitim seminer işte bize 12 bir
şeyler anlattılar Tabii şey hoşuma
gidiyor konu benim konum biliyorum
mesleğimle ilgili bir şey teknolojide
seviyorum bayağı keyif aldım Sonra
otururken birden Herkes kalktı ben Tabi
nereye gittiklerini de anlamadım ama
herkes kalkınca Ben de kalktım şimdi
soracağım soramıyorum ederim Herkes
gitti iş yarım kaldı tam öğrenemedik
dediler Sen işe başladın artık hep
geleceksin Ben o gün belediyede işe
başlamışım Ama bunun algısı bende yok
Onu bir öğle tatili olduğunu bile
Sonraları düşününce anlıyorum şimdi bir
hafta falan Ben kimseye bir şey
soramıyorum Herkes çok meşgul zaten
dosyalar var video geliyor vatandaş olan
geliyor gidiyor çok hareketli bir ortam
Herkes her şeyi biliyor bir tek ben
bilmiyorum Bir hafta boyunca
herkes denerken gelip herkezden geç
giderek kaçta işe geliyor öğle tatili
saatleri ne akşam kaçta çıkıyor ve
Burada ne iş yapılıyor anlamaya çalıştım
bu yaz Anladım
schimb uaci başlangıçtan sonra bana
nasıl bir söz söylediler sen hep
geleceksin diye bu soru çok güzel
dinlemişim ve o günden beri harbi
belediyeye gidiyorum
bundan da büyük keyif alıyorum Tabi o
gün Tek Bir bilgisayarla başlayan macera
sonrasında devam eden ve gelişen bir
kent bilgi sistemine dönüş Tüm
bu planlama çalışmalarının Bilgisayar
ortamında yapılması ve kent bütününde
yayılmasıyla Bana da kendimi geliştirme
imkanı sunmuş oldu
yine bir mezun Üniversitesi olarak
başladım bu macerada
bilmenin ve öğrenmenin sonu olmadığını
ve insanın bildikçe özgürleştiğini iki
çalışmaların çok önemli olduğunu ekibin
bir kısmı da burada Hoş geldiniz sizde
hiç yalnız bırakmıyorlar ekip böyle
birşey birlikte çalışmanın çok iyi ve
olumlu sonuçlar verebildiği o zaman fark
ettim Ha ben bunu her yeni çalışmada
fark etmeye devam ediyorum
belediye bünyesinde yaptım İlk önemli
çalışma bütün kentin dijital bir
altlığının oluşturulması ydı
Bu da demek ki elimizdeki bütün
bilgilerin şehirde gördüğünüz iki
boyutlu üç boyutlu her türlü şeyin bina
köşelerinden Ben elektrik direklerine
elektrik direklerinden duvarlar ara
duvarlardan çeşmelere aklınıza
gelebilecek her türlü bilginin koordinat
olarak bilgisayara girilmesini
sağlamaktı bize Tabi bu bilgilerin çoğu
belediyede yoktu hepsi değişik
kurumlarda ydı o yüzden öncelikle bu
bilgilerin nerede olduğunu anlayabilmek
bu kurumlarla iletişime geçmek Gerekirse
protokoller yapmak bilgiye erişmek ve
gidip Hatta bunları bire bir bilgisayara
aktarmak gerekiyordu
en çok Birlik kadastro Müdürlüğünde o
değildi İlk önce oradan çalışmaya
başladık Ve onunla yaptığımız Pro ve
sonrasında kadastro Müdürlüğü'ne gittik
üç aylık belediye çalışanı adam
belediyeden yeni bir kuruma geçiyordum
da belediyeye tam oluşmamış tıme
kadastro müdürlüğüne ne de mesaiye
başladım belediyede çalışırken Tabii
kadar Şuradaki ekip çok daha farklıydı
yaşça hepsi büyük çok deneyimliler ve
benim bilmediğim çok şey biliyorlardı
son derece disiplinli tek disiplinli bir
ekip Herşey bire bir arazide kontrol
ediliyor tek tek bilgisayara giriyor bir
yanlışlık olursa çünkü bütün çalışmanın
yanlış devam etmesine neden olacak bir
şey o yüzden bu disiplinde iki biçimde
çalışma hayatına ilişkin çok şey
öğrendim tabi bunların arasındaki en
önemli şey de kahve yapmak oldu çünkü
öğrendim ki Aslında ben en gençler
içmezdim ve hep kahveleri en geç ve için
özel yapıyor Kahveyi yap yapmayı
öğrendim de diyebiliriz Hiç güzel kahve
yapamıyorum Hala da yapamam ama iş o
kadar çok önemli şeyler öğrendim bir
ekip çalışmasında iki arkadaşlarına
nasıl birlikte hareket edilir sorular
sorunlar nasıl dile getirir ve bunlara
nasıl çözüm bulunur hepsini o çalışma
sırasında Öğrenmiş oldum
şu mama Tabi bu çalışmada aynı zamanda
bütün Cadde sokakları Bütün bina
köşelerinde ister istemez Çanakkale'deki
her şeyde koordinat olarak da bilir bir
vaziyete geldim Türkiye'de ilk defa
yapılan bir şey değildi ve yeni yeni
önemsenen bir konuydu ama benim her şeyi
bilmem gerekiyor çünkü bana çok soru
soruyorlardı bunu bu da sorulara cevap
verebilmem için sürekli kendimi öğrenme
yönünde bir alışkanlık kazandırmaya
yönelme yöneltme neden oldu bu
alışkanlığı geliştirmeye çalıştım
öğrenmem gerekiyor devamlı sorular
geliyor gerek geri geliyor bu sistem
devamlı gelişen ve yenilenen bir sistem
Tabii yeni çalışmalar yapmak için bu Bu
bir itici güç oldu yeni şeyler R
yönelmek yeni bilgileri bilmeyenlerle
daha az bilenlerle benden çok bilenlerle
paylaşmak
Bu çok da hoşuma gitti Tabii aynı
zamanda yerel yönetimlerde çalışmak bu
yönden de çok zevkli ve zorlayıcı
Çünkü bir kent gelişiyor ve onun gelişen
ihtiyaçlarına göre bütün hizmet
üretenlerin de kentle beraber
kendilerini geliştirmeleri gerekiyor Bu
süreç hiç bitmiyor ki Kent canlı bir
organizma gibi ortak ihtiyaçları var
Bunları karşılıyor ama geliştikçe yeni
yine Aslında akla gelmeyen bambaşka
ihtiyaçlarda ortaya çıkıyor
Şu Kent yaşayanların ihtiyaçlarını
anlayabilmek için sizin de onlarla
beraber bunları özümseme niz lazım
web ve değişken ve sürekli bi Farklı
olan bir organizmayı da organize etmek
Aslında çok bu
ihtiyaçları karşılamak gerçekten her
zaman zorlayıcı bu kentte yaşayan
herkesin memnun olabilir bir sistem
oluşturmak da mümkün değil o yüzden
çoğunluğun sesini duymak gerekiyor Yani
kenti organize edebilmek için kendi
dinlemek gerekiyor ve Biz Üç kadın
yönetici olarak kendi dinlemeye
çalışıyoruz ihtiyaçlarına göre Kent
gelişimine yön vermeye çalışıyoruz ya
ancak dinleyip anlayarak birikimlerimizi
kenti
yansıtarak rahat ve konforlu bir yaşam
ortamı oluşturabileceğini biliyoruz Ve
bu rahat ve konforlu ortamda da bu mutlu
bir hayat süre bilmemiz mümkün şuanda
Aslında tesadüfen Çok doğru bir yerden
başladığın
kendimi geliştirme alışkanlığının
hayatta ne kadar önemli olduğunu
anlayabiliyorum
örenmek de bilmek arasında gerçekten bir
fark varmış Bunu da şu anda Artık
tamamen fark ettim Bu bir şey öğrenmek
haberdar olmayı bilgiye erişmeyi
sağlıyor ama bilmek anlamayı ve işi
yapabilme olur iyi olanaklı kılıyor
ancak bilerek özgürleşme biliyoruz
düşüncelerimizi eylemlerimizi korkutucu
uygulaya biliyoruz
biliyor olmak herkese ve insana cesaret
veriyor iş yapabilme gücü veriyor rü
ülkemizin iş yapabilme gücüne bu derece
ihtiyacı olduğu bu dönemde Umarım
hepimiz bilerek cesaretle işlerimizi
özenle yaparız Teşekkür ediyorum iyi
akşamlar diliyorum